good morning John there comes a time in
every top creators career when somebody
comes by with a really big check and
says wow you've built an amazing
community on this platform we'd like you
to move it to a different platform I
fancy myself something of a creator
advocate so I am in favor of people
getting paid I just think people should
know for sure what they're getting paid
for and there are lots of different
things that you might be being paid for
in situations like this the old-school
version of this which is kind of where
it all came from is that a star builds
up a career and over time audiences gain
an affinity for that star they know what
to expect from that star and they will
go see a movie
largely because that star is in it first
year of Andy and Parks and Rec that goes
well then you get all buff and you
become Peter quill and then it continues
to snowball and now you're the leading
guy in Jurassic world things are going
well this is I guess fine like it feels
like it kind of crowds out other people
who might be playing those roles but
it's functionally how things were and
ultimately Chris Pratt and the movie
studios and the audiences are all doing
the things they want to do people are
looking for a movie to go watch in a
familiar face is a nice door into that
movie but what if you're trying to bring
people somewhere they're not used to
going well this is why Jeffrey
Katzenberg and companies spent over a
billion dollars on content for kwibi
a new platform that provides quick bytes
of video that you can watch in less than
10 minutes thus solving a problem that
absolutely no one on earth has and also
one that misunderstands the power of
celebrity when deciding what movie to go
see a celebrity might inform that
decision they're not gonna follow a
celebrity to a new platform because
people don't actually care very much
about celebrities I don't think that
this is necessarily bad though like I'm
in favor of billionaires spending their
money and it doesn't seem like it's
hurting anyone and heck maybe I'm wrong
and it's gonna be successful but the
thing that I'm more interested in more
thoughtful about it and more ambivalent
about is when creators have really deep
relationships with their audiences and
they have existing projects and products
that they then move the entire thing to
a new platform and get paid to do that
so they're doing it not because it
provides a better service or a better
experience for their audience but
because they're being paid to do it
this isn't about
celebrity lending their fame to a new
project it's saying like I've built an
audience I have built a community and
you need people on your platform and so
I will sell you my audience like in this
case you are selling those people and
that like you need to be really careful
in Jake getting paid to move to mixer is
about his audience it's about changing
user behavior it's about buying market
share with money which is something that
Microsoft has plenty of and then also
hopefully eventually drawing other
smaller creators to that platform where
a new audience is growing and those
creators will not be compensated for
that switch
Spotify putting Joe Rogan in the last
podcast on the left under exclusive
licenses this worries me more because in
the case of twitch versus mixer it's
Amazon versus Microsoft right like let
them fight it out but with podcasts
you're taking content out of an open
ecosystem that no one controls and
putting it inside a closed ecosystem
that is owned by a company so Spotify is
not paying to compete with another
corporation they're paying to compete
with an open standard of the internet
which podcasting somehow despite all the
odds has so far held on to I want to be
clear that these situations aren't
always bad and that yeah sometimes
creators gotta get paid but always as
creators and as audiences let's be
honest about what's being sold what are
the pieces here the talent the fame the
influence the audience the power all of
that stuff has value whether or not it
gets sold and it's up to each individual
creator to decide what to do with that
value for some people it's writing books
and making tic TOCs Sean I'll see you on
Tuesday I can't believe you made a
tick-tock and also you can't believe you
have way more followers than me already